these people are demanding the state
provides alternative energy to public
hospitals schools and police stations
they say corruption and mismanagement
are to blame for an energy crisis in
South Africa
and opposition parties Civil Society
groups and trade unions are challenging
the government in court as a result of
that Financial loss and the Looting and
the stealing that has been taking place
there it has meant furthermore that the
mismanagement the building of poor
plants has delivered the sort of energy
crisis that we have so the door
literally sits it's not demand
outstripping Supply in this instance
it's a government incapable of being
able to give Supply and augment energy
the power disruptions are affecting
people's homes and businesses and are
slowing down economic growth
some areas can go without electricity
for more than 10 hours a day
playing South Africa for more than 15
years many people here can't afford to
buy solar panels or generators for them
getting off the grid isn't an option
president Sarah ramaphosa recently
appointed the country's first
electricity minister to try and provide
South Africa with a more stable energy
Supply but his government says that it
doesn't have the capacity to end
blackouts immediately
that's not what sakumzi marcobela wants
to hear he owns a popular restaurant in
Soweto Township before this we used to
make money but now instead of investing
our money being able to train our staff
we have to buy your solar we thought the
solar is enough we have to buy generator
the generator is not enough you have to
buy diesel as well so those are coasts
that we're not ready for Rolling
blackouts are common in many parts of
Africa but some people living here say
they shouldn't happen here in South
Africa the most industrialized economy
on the continent
and as far as they are concerned this
crisis shouldn't have been allowed to
happen in the first place
Johannesburg